hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
the relationships between human beings
and something greater than them which we
can call the divine
is a matter that nearly every culture
has some viewpoints on the ancient
greeks were no exception
and heraclitus of ephesus thinks that
it's a
important matter too judging by the
fragments that we have
of his work of course we don't have his
entire doctrine because it's only
fragmentary but what we do have
is indeed quite
you might say not just reflective of the
matrix
that it's coming out of but also quite
critical
of that matrix of ancient greek religion
as well
and we can say that heraclitus although
not providing us with an entire doctrine
is providing
us with some very suggestive
ideas that have at least to some degree
some internal coherence we can speak
of a heredian view on the divine
now before going into what his views
actually are
we need to specify that when we're using
this term
divine it's actually referring to more
than one greek
word so in the broadest sense there is
the dimon
and we're going to see that pop up in
several of the fragments
that includes the gods but also includes
all sorts of other
beings as well that are in some respect
beyond the human so tutelary spirits
or the spirit of a particular place you
know if we think about
uh nymphs you know in in a river area
those those could be daimones and the
daimones
later on in greek ideas particularly
philosophical ideas end up being sort of
go-betweens the
the gods the olympian deities and human
beings
but it also includes this entire what
what's often referred to as the
cothonian
realm as well and heraclitus doesn't
talk that much about that
he also uses the term theos
and theo in the plural meaning the gods
or god and he will name
one of them um sort of
we'll see why i say sort of in a moment
as zeus right
but um he also talks about the lord the
anax
at delphi a knox is a ancient greek term
that means it gets translated as
lord but can also mean something like
leader or ruler
and so there's there's a wide range of
things that are falling under the divine
let's say the things
i don't want to say supernatural because
we don't want to import
later conceptions of you know
a pure nature and then something going
beyond it that's not there in heraclitus
as a matter of fact the gods help us to
understand
the nature of things better as we're
going to see
if we follow them or take our guidance
from them
so the first thing that i think is
useful to start with and there's there's
you know quite a few fragments that do
talk about the divine and the human
so it's kind of an arbitrary selection
where we want to start
the one that i would like to start with
is fragment 78
and we're talking about the deals
numbering of the fragments here
and it says it's often translated as
human
nature we'll stick with that for a
moment human nature
lacks good judgments but the gods
have good judgments so what we see here
is a sort of elevation of the gods over
human beings
we could say in logical or
epistemological however you want to
frame it terms
the gods are smarter than us they come
to better judgments they're better
informed
than us human beings now i
i did want to say something about this
choice of the word
nature we could also say the
accustomed way of human beings
the term here is ethos
and it's ethos anthropon
entropay on means human right it's just
a
sort of qualifier ethos
is often translated as character as it
will be
indeed in the probably most famous
and most often quoted fragment by
heraclitus which is uh number 119
which says that character is destiny
right
not a very good translation actually in
some respect
but it's the same word there ethos
so how should we translate it here
it's the accustomed way in which human
beings approach things
so human beings who are behaving like
regular old human beings lack
good judgments and the word there for
judgment gnome
meaning something that can be verbalized
and then
shared with others the gods actually
are in a privileged position with
respect to us so they
have better judgments than us what are
some examples of this
so here clydus is going to talk about
some misunderstandings of the divine
on the part of humans so one of them is
praying to images
and he has this really interesting
metaphor
or analogy right here he says
that human beings um vainly purify
themselves with blood when they're
defiled with it which is like someone
who stepped into mud using mud to wash
himself
so that's an interesting observation
there about you know ancient sacrificial
religion
but then he goes a little bit further
and he gets to something
more radical he says
in their ignorance of the true nature of
gods
and heroes he also does say the word
heroes we'll come back to that in a
moment
they pray to these statues which is like
someone chatting to a house
now isn't that an interesting
similitude there an interesting way to
open our eyes
to pray to a statue
we might also say this too about praying
to our own mental images
of whatever the divine happens to be is
like
trying to have a conversation with a
house
and this is a little bit of a digression
but how many people
in their prayer lives have said you know
i find
prayer rather unsatisfying because i
i talk to god all the time and god
doesn't say anything to me
well if prayer and and you know the
object of prayer
is like this it would be like talking
with a house the house isn't going to
say anything to you
you can talk to the house as much as you
like because
you're a human being but it's never
going to respond to you or even talking
to
a book you know saying oh show me
passage numbers such and such i suppose
nowadays you you've got your smart ais
that you can
talk to all you like but you're really
still just talking into the void
for the most part although they're
collecting data on you
as you do that but why do people do this
well it's because they don't know
what the gods or heroes
are like hopoyum in in greek right
what kind of things they are and it's
interesting that he says heroes because
the ancient greeks did recognize these
heroic figures who could themselves
sometimes become
divine and be you know like assimilated
into the pantheon
the way here uh heracles was and
um you know oftentimes these would have
a cult to them
at a particular place with rituals and
shrines and
people would make offerings and pray to
theseus
or heracles or you know whoever it
happens to be
at that point in in time and space
so this is one mistaken view he says
something else that
is along similar lines when it comes to
the divine
processions and rituals
so he says this and this is in fragment
15
about the worship of dionysus
now in order to understand this i think
it's very helpful to know
that dionysos was not just as you might
find looking it up on wikipedia they got
wine dianisos was also the god of
intoxication
and all the things that go along with it
and the rituals surrounding dionysus
were in fact quite uh reflective of that
he was also
a fertility god so you know
there were a lot of phalluses and there
was a lot of revelry and there was a lot
of getting drunk and a lot of
you know crazy stuff going on so he says
if the procession they perform and the
hymn they chant in order
in honor of the phallus were not
undertaken for dionysos there would be
nothing more disgraceful
what's he getting at there there's
certain things that when it comes to
certain
objects of of religion and faith that we
see
as okay in those circumstances but they
wouldn't be okay in other circumstances
now the ancient greeks were polytheists
so there's a number of different gods
and heraclitus is going to point out
that in fact the anissos for whom they
rave and celebrate the linea
one of the festivals is the same as
hades
hades is the literally the unseen god
aides
the one who is the king of the
underworld the king
of death and of the dead
so these are almost at opposite from
each other the vitality of dionysus
versus the
you know the austere
timelessness and nothing ever happening
really
of hades so
heraclitus is saying these are really
the same thing
you're worshiping the same divine being
or interacting with the same divine
being
and the mistake is thinking that they
are different from each other
so if we abandon what we might call
all too human ways of understanding the
divine
how better can we understand the divine
this is where it starts to get
both very murky and very
interesting from a speculative
perspective
which i think you could say is sort of
the hallmark of
of heraclitus so
in fragment 36 he talks about an
order a cosmos that's a term that we use
to understand
the universe as a whole but it's good to
keep in mind that for heraclitus this
cosmos
includes what we can call cosmological
processes he in the fragments that we
have we have the suggestion
of a vast cosmic interconnected process
which includes transmutation from one
element to another to another fire being
a privileged one
um there's all sorts of you know
speculation about exactly what's going
on there and
unfortunately we have to guess at it
because we don't have his full
doctrine we may someday recover a
manuscript of his own nature but until
then we have to do guesswork but this
this order is there now here's what he
says
about it this is quite interesting
particularly given all that we've said
so far about the gods
right so he says that
here we are order cosmos was not made by
god or human so
that order is there we won't necessarily
say before the gods
but the gods didn't create it there is
no transcendent creator god
in this this viewpoint that he has
instead the gods live
within this cosmos so he goes on and he
says
this cosmos always was and is
and shall be so we're talking about
eternity there
an ever living fire flaring up in
regular measures and dying down in
regular
measures so it's very interesting here
it's not
just a random process there is an
order to the order itself that we all
inhabit
now he also tells us something
that helps us to expand our conception
of god and where the divine fits into
this
there's a very suggestive fragment and
it would be nice if we actually had
more to go on with this but it's
quite interesting to think about by
itself he says
there is only one wise and he uses the
word hen there and he uses the word
sophos so
you know one and and wise and then he
tells us that
it is willing
and not willing to be called by the name
of zeus thalain
is the greek verb there for willing
so choosing bidding it in a certain way
it chooses and also chooses not to be
called by the name of zeus meaning that
it could be called in
many other ways or perhaps it chooses
not to be called
at all but it is the one wise thing
and then a little bit uh later on in
fragment
67 he is going to
say another thing that i think a lot of
people have picked up on
that god whole theos which would be
you know this thing that is is willing
to be called
zeus he tells us that it's a set of
opposites
it is day and night winter and summer
war and peace fullness and
hunger and then he goes on and he says
he changes like fire which when mixed
with
spices or incenses is named according to
the savor
or odor of each
so there's this idea that god in a
certain way not only is these opposites
or
encompasses these opposites god pervades
the cosmic process god pervades what we
encounter
as these individuated categories
and think to be sort of opposites of
each other which means that god is in
some respect beyond opposition and
encompasses
oppositions that we are used to
now there is one other passage that i
thought is very important to bring up
here and this
gives us a little bit of paradox
he tells us that the role of war or
fighting or strife polomos is that among
other things
it reveals gods and humans
and reveals them in what way it says
war is the father of all and king of all
some he reveals as gods
others as humans some he makes slaves
others
free so conflict strife reveals
what things are in relation to each
other
and perhaps to themselves and to the
rest of the world
including the astute observer that would
be somebody like heraclitus
taking his cues from the divine so what
does that mean though does that mean
that god is created by war
we just saw that in this other passage
god is both war and peace
but here he says in the plural gods
he doesn't say god as such right
so that's one way of understanding it
maybe there's like you know
uh think about heracles right if it
wasn't for the conflicts that heracles
got in his ten labors
he wouldn't have been able to be
heracles this is a commonplace an
ancient philosophy
but that's that's well worth thinking
about that that
war plays a central role in this somehow
there's another discussion that's quite
important he talks about
humans as essentially being children
in relation to the divine
and hear the word divine some in some
translations
it's supernatural is not theos
it's actually dimon and he
you know he's laying out an analogy
there
the human being is like a child
a child that's understood by a human
being is clearly lacking
some of the capacities of the fully
developed human being the
god or the divine the dimon is like that
in relation to the human
and here i i mentioned you know we want
to bring up this famous passage
that he says that you know it's often
translated as character
is destiny but actually the word there
is ethos
and he says ethos anthropo right the
character of a person is their dimon
so in a way there's like
you could say that there's a bit of the
divine that's coming along with us
everywhere we go
and is revealing to us the kind of
person
that we're going to be based on our
character based on our
path our way another thing
that is is uh very important to to bring
up as well
is the notion of a
law that is actually
a divine law and he tells us that you
know human beings have their own
laws um and
and that you know there's actually a a
deeper law that governs all of them
that covers everything else and that is
a law
of the gods this is you might say the
beginning
of a conception of natural law theory
although it's just one fragment and it
doesn't go any further with that
finally the last thing that we have to
bring up is again one of these very very
famous
passages so you know now we've
understood heraclitus's perspective as
best as we can about the nature of the
divine and
relationship of human beings who are
usually in the dark
and wandering around and mixed up about
the divine in relation
to the divine can we get any advice
or any information from the divine
there's only one passage that actually
suggests this and this has been picked
up on by many people because of the way
in which it's framed but i think it's
it's good to end on because it could be
generalized to talk about all of this as
well
he tells us that the lord whose oracle
is in delphi right and that remember
lord is
a knox and the oracle is in delphi
woolkid that's apollo
so now he's not naming a god but instead
he's
he's signifying a god he's giving signs
there's a little bit of self-reference
here neither speaks
nor conceals but
gives signs some other translations
indicates i don't
i don't like indicates that much because
it makes it a little bit more clear
than we want so he doesn't speak leg a
he doesn't he doesn't tell you anything
directly
nor does he conceal
uh it's a word that we get cryptic from
right he's not being
cryptic he's not hiding anything from
you but instead he provides
signs it's a mining he gives you
something that you can think about it
might be a parable might be a proverb it
might be
just some things that are connected to
each other and you have to figure out
the meaning
so there's no like straightforward
mode of interpretation of it and you're
always
responsible for what you read into it
some people
in approaching the article is oh the
oracle just hides everything from us
or they say oh the oracle's totally
clear with us nope
instead we get signs and that's the best
that we're going to get
and if we read those signs correctly
here's here's where we can use this as
sort of an interpretive key
then we can understand everything else
or at least a portion of it
in the universe and in relation to the
divine
and about us as human beings
you